[Music]
hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast our
54th
live stream third 53rd live stream
um a bit of advice i think probably you
ought to sit down for this because
things are afoot in the world i don't
know that any of us saw this coming
but it has happened um we have seen
joe biden nominally win the presidency
of the united states
is that your understanding that is
certainly what has been
declared um by most of the news outlets
as of i don't know an hour or two ago
yeah an hour or two ago
um so we're obviously going to talk a
great deal about uh
what the implications of this are and i
must say
um strangely although we have been in
slow motion for days
watching this um this eventuality emerge
one state at a time and then
uh one percentage point at a time
the fact of it is still a bit stunning i
must say
or maybe fact of it is the wrong way to
describe it
so what do you think what do you think
is actually
is actually emerging and what will
happen well
um i have the sense i mean we saw
obviously the
very odd press conference at the
landscaping
shop outside of philadelphia this
morning yes not everyone paying
attention
may be aware of this though so there was
a press conference
a press conference with the rudy rudy
giuliani
who was in front of a
rather robust hose reel
it was a nice hose reel i mean this was
definitely like heavy duty
this was not a homeowner version and
anyway he um
delivered a a speech about
anomalies that are alleged in the
electoral process especially in
philadelphia and brought out several
poll watchers and had them describe
experiences they had had
and vowed to continue fighting in the
courts
their testimony so to speak suggesting
that they had not been allowed to do the
jobs that they were brought in to do
right and uh so anyway there's a
question about what one makes of it
my sense is that
well a we're obviously in a very
dangerous situation that
many of us saw coming where we have an
election that many people
do not believe is legitimate and
we have court challenges
which are being issued as
networks are declaring victors in the
election
we have the danger of um
courts delivering us a a
verdict which will then cause who dis
believes the process is fair to flip
to the other side um and anyway uh
there's a question about what will
happen i must say i expect
that what will happen is um joe biden
will be
inaugurated i think trump will
step down um
yeah which means that that we were wrong
if that comes to pass right like we both
thought that trump would win
not having voted for him ourselves um
but having understood that neither of
the two uh the two main
candidates for president uh came without
real danger
right but we certainly a couple of
months ago
i felt that trump was quite very likely
to win and just in the last few weeks i
was like
i'm not i'm not as sure as i was and
uh what is true in the last i guess it's
for three and a half days now since the
polls have been closed
um is that i am less and less sure
that we have intact democratic processes
at almost any level
and that is terrifying yeah it is
it is terrifying um and you know we
could take this apart in lots of ways
i would say um baseline would be the
recognition
that there are literally trillions of
dollars at stake
in a u.s presidential election and
that's an awful lot of incentive
for shenanigans and
um the fact is we're dealing with you
know at the
upper echelon of these major political
parties we're dealing
with absolutely ruthless people who uh
will use any tools at their disposal and
so you know at some level personally i
wouldn't put it past
uh i wouldn't put it past them to engage
in fraud but then there are lots of
reasons that you know
there are things that people would do
that they don't do because they're
illegal and the penalties are high
you know are we in that situation and i
you know i don't think we can know and
some people won't engage in fraud
when it comes to tampering with
democracy because they're actually
patriots
oh and actually have a moral center that
tells them that they do not behave that
way
a huge number of people would not engage
in fraud in fact i think most people
wouldn't but the problem is there's a
question about whether the process
selects for
indeed exactly the opposite the process
is
you know as we have said about so many
things the process itself is
evolutionary
and uh it is not as clear here what
um the response might be but it will
involve an understanding
of evolutionary forces as well
absolutely
um so i would also point out
that whatever has happened in the
election let's assume that the election
uh is uh being conducted honorably that
the counting is being conducted
honorably i've seen a lot of
debunking of claims of fraud and a lot
of the debunking is
fairly compelling there are explanations
for lots of stuff that people are
initially
concerned about which doesn't mean that
that's true for everything
but um and there will be error
for sure in in a vote that
is this huge without there inherently
being an indication of fraud
right er error error will exist in this
error will exist and you would expect it
to be
uh equally uh likely in both directions
um you know which is why recounts cause
numbers to shift because there's always
a certain amount of noise in the system
um however i would point out the
following thing
the tech platforms are absolutely
monolithic in their support for one side
over the other and they have both
tremendous power they have no legal
restrictions and
we have seen lots of evidence of them
playing
uh games with controlling you know
who gets to say what when a warning is
appended to this person's perspective or
that person
so the fact is the heavy hand on the
scale of the tech platforms is
undeniable right
now whether it's permissible we can
argue about but we can't argue that that
it
you know wasn't there because we saw it
up close
now what i think is clear is that this
was a squeaker of an election
right now it may not be in the end all
that close
at the electoral college level but
obviously the reason that we're hanging
on
what are we five days later here
four days later um you know still
you know arguing about precincts and
what percentage of the ballots are
counted and all of that is that this is
a very close election and so
i think it is clear and a huge number of
people voted
which means on both sides it's it's very
close
and the numbers if if we are to believe
the numbers now uh are something like 70
million
to 73 million votes at the popular vote
level for trump versus biden
which is a the opposite of a landslide
right the opposite of a mandate um that
even though trump voters and trump
supporters are pilloried and lambasted
and denounced and called reprehensible
and all of this
almost half of the people who went out
to vote or
you know stayed in to vote and took
their ballots to the ballot boxes of the
mailboxes
still voted for him so this this
i've already seen claims that this is a
mandate against
socialism for instance um but
what it what it certainly is not is an
indication
that the entire country is in lockstep
quite the opposite
no quite the opposite what were the
numbers you cited i believe it's
something like 73 million and 70 million
at this point 73 million for for biden
and 70 million for trump and of course
there will be those who
disagree with those numbers on the basis
that some of the votes are
are fraudulent oh some of the ballots
are fraudulent but um those are the
those are the numbers ish that i'm
seeing so very a very divided
um very uh active election
large number of people voted but what i
would argue is that given
the role that big tech is playing in our
lives
i think the chances that their influence
which they obviously
wielded played a decisive difference in
the selection
the chances are very very high right so
whatever it is that we conclude from
this
we really ought to recognize that nobody
ought to be crowing here
about their victory and what it means
because what it means is actually quite
frightening
and it's uh you know it's not a mandate
for
anything it's chaos yeah it's chaos
um it is at some level uh
a reveal of continued influence peddling
having an effect
on elections as you would think it must
all the time but this in fact
was one of the things that trump went
into office the first time
uh arguing against that he didn't he
didn't have the kind of influence to
peddle
in order to get people on his side
that all of the mainstream candidates
from the republican party and the
democratic party
have had and are fighting hard to retain
yeah now we talk a lot about influence
peddling and people
i get a lot of correspondence people are
um
i think puzzled by by the term
okay but i would say that there's
something that i think well should we i
i didn't i didn't know that
should we define it then well i mean
it's just you know it's
uh selling your power power earned in a
democratic process selling your power to
moneyed interests and i think part of
the problem is that
influence peddling is supposed to be
illegal right
and in a narrow sense it's illegal but
in a broad sense
it's most definitely not illegal which
is to say that mechanisms evolve
that remain you know inside of the
legally tolerated behavior but that
clearly
amount to influence peddling yeah um
a lot of quid pro quos this for that
could be seen as influence peddling and
if you are simply exchanging
one good for another one vote for a pro
of future promise any number of things
some of those will be strictly illegal
and some of them
the law won't have anything to say about
at all well you know
um i remember from a civics class when i
must have been
i don't know was i nine years old and i
maybe the one time in my life i heard
the term
log rolling which was a description
of what would sometimes uh be
termed how the sausage is made that log
rolling
in a in the american political context
is basically
involves trading votes which is was you
know this was described
in a civics book it was not it's not
illegal and
it's not even bad necessarily i've never
heard it before and i don't get the
metaphor
well the i i don't know exactly even
though what it's a reference
to but the idea is imagining people on
rivers as
you know in logging camps moving
downstream i i just i don't
i can't even fathom what actually it
means
um yeah i don't know maybe it has to do
with the turn of the logs i mean you've
seen these
you know on a river with them right but
i don't understand
what the idea was i mean it's possible i
imagined the whole thing
but this is this is the moment you were
paying attention in school
it was one of those it was on the list
um but
the the idea was that people in congress
trade votes for things and there's
nothing
inherently wrong with this in other
words you know you can have people
on two sides of the aisle who decide hey
you know i really want
this thing i think it's good for the
country you don't feel that strongly
about it you want that thing and i don't
feel that strongly about it
how about we team up that's a natural
process and so the point is
that's not influence peddling it does
grade into something else
quid pro quo's you know of a different
sort
quid pro quos between elected officials
and
moneyed interests are of course uh they
are illegal but there are you know an
indefinitely large number of ways that
you can do it
that it can't be proven and i will tell
you
um the question of you know deniability
plausible and otherwise is so central
to the questions of influence peddling
that you know
we really need to all get on the same
page about it but the
fact of the
house having impeached the president
um which i would argue was the result
of a more or less
out in the open conspiracy against the
president since he took office
that found something that actually was
very disturbing of course you know the
abuse of power by the president
was real where the president was trying
to get
uh hunter biden of all people
investigated uh
in ukraine and so
anyway you've got something very
troubling on
both sides you've got a political
apparatus that's out of control
hell-bent on destroying a democratically
elected president that then does find
something disturbing
you know arguably justifying of an
impeachment
but what is it that was you know at the
core
of the abuse of power
by by trump was a question of
influence peddling by hunter biden of
his father's influence
right and then what comes spilling out
at the end of this
uh electoral cycle is evidence of how
deep the rabbit hole goes now does any
of it
necessarily say that you know joe biden
was aware of it
no on the other hand you know
it is suggestive of something that we
just don't
see that's going on all of all the time
that does involve you know foreign
powers and it involves our interests as
americans being compromised
because there's some sort of an economic
exchange going on behind the scenes that
we're just never
made aware of right very dangerous stuff
it is
um uh here's something else that's
dangerous
you ready oh yeah yeah i think you've
probably seen this
uh hold on just a second
okay here we go zach um show my screen
here
uh so and so just reported this a tweet
just reported white house staff are
starting to look for jobs
employers considering them should know
there are consequences for anyone
for hiring anyone who helped trump
attack american values
find out how at the trump accountability
project
the trump accountability project says
remember what they
did we must never forget those who
furthered the trump agenda
we should welcome in our fellow
americans with whom we should welcome in
our fellow americans with whom we differ
politically
but those who took a paycheck from the
trump administration should not profit
from their efforts to tear our democracy
apart
the world should never forget those who
when faced with a decision
chose to put their money their time and
their reputations behind separating
children from their families
encouraging racism and anti-semitism and
negligently causing the unnecessary loss
of life and economic devastation from
our country's failed response to the
covet-19 pandemic
um i will give
trump no no props at all for his
response to covet 19.
it was the worst series of actions of
his presidency
but the other things on this list uh are
either
uh false or um extreme exaggerations
and um that's not really the point here
though is it yeah
the point the point is
can they hear themselves do they have
any idea and incidentally i would
recommend
um you know so i've i've put myself i've
signed up with a
with a throwaway email account um to
find out what they're up to as they
start to be up to something this trump
accountability project
but at the same time before you respond
here we have
alexandria ocasio-cortez aoc asking is
anyone archiving these trump sycophants
for when they try to downplay or deny
their complicity in the future
i foresee decent possibility of many
deleted tweets writings photos in the
future
okay um with 329
000 likes yeah and just one more
before we uh talk about this your
brother
eric quote tweeted aoc in that tweet and
said you should google section a of the
reserve index
perhaps there should be a minimal
history exam to let woke people into the
left you don't seem to understand the
left it's history or its objectives you
sound like the other team
you aren't the left you're the other
guys
this of course is something that he and
you and i and many others have been
saying throughout
no our critique of this horrifying
nonsense that is happening on the far
left of the party is not evidence that
we are on the right it is evidence that
we are actually
over the left from when the left meant
openness
and inquiry and the ability to disagree
with people
without conflating that disagreement
with a complete dismantling of them as
human beings
so the section a of the reserve index
apparently this section a is
has been disappeared now through no
nefarious means
uh the reserve index actually i'll just
um
pull it oh god where did my thing go um
the reserve index
um just you don't have to show this sec
this is just wikipedia
it's you know there's a lot there's a
lot here um
is and i was going to read it but now i
can't find
it so the reserve index as opposed to
the security index the security index is
the list by the fbi
of people that the fbi considers
dangerous who might commit acts inimical
to the national defense and public
safety of the united states in time of
emergency
the reserve index on the other hand
again i'm just quoting wikipedia listed
all left-wingers and individuals
suspected of being a communist by the
1950s for instance there were 5 000
names under the security index while the
reserve index had 50
000 in the chicago field office
some of those people were martin luther
king and
oh i feel like i don't see it here now
but i feel like robeson was on that
paul robeson yep that makes sense and um
it was
hoover uh j edgar hoover who put dr
martin luther king jr
on the reserve index in retaliation for
and again i'm just quoting wikipedia his
civil rights work and worldwide
popularity
yep um so uh it will not surprise you if
it sounds like you didn't see it but
i saw aoc's tweet also and
could not restrain myself i had to
respond zach will you put up my
response to her i said you are an
elected representative in a democratic
republic and you are setting the stage
for retribution against fellow citizens
for the crime of holding a different
opinion
it's un-american you should stop it and
counsel others to do the same and for
anyone who doubts that i wrote that
i apparently misspelled counsel there
are two different ways yeah so you can
spell it yeah
um so here's the thing there's a
a battle coming about this first of all
this is a terrible instinct this is an
absolutely appalling instinct that you
are going to
hound the people leaving office
and punished them for the very fact of
being on the other side
and i mean not only does it uh forebode
truly awful possibilities
um but at the at a minimum it reveals
that they thrive on division
oh right that the the
extremists really on the left side of
the democratic party
thrive on division have no interest in
re-establishing that we're all americans
and all human and that we are all in
this together and should be seeking
a better and more prosperous and more
equal
um but not equitable future
uh it it just it puts the light all of
that they're not interested in that
yep now i will say um trump is
far from innocent in this of course his
uh his whole lock her
up thing during the 2016 campaign was
appalling for the same
reason but at some level we have to
recognize that we as
americans have every interest in
preventing
this arms race right where we treat the
other side as criminals
um and we start to recognize the
mechanisms that allow this to be
justified
so if you chase down what aoc goes on to
say in her next tweet
you know it's about accountability and
there are these
syllogisms that are used to protect this
absolutely vile behavior
which have to do you know you will hear
um
you know that there is freedom of speech
but there's no freedom from
accountability
right and on the one hand that's true on
the other hand
it's what's implied right accountability
is one thing nobody is saying
we shouldn't remember who supported whom
and frankly you and i have advocated
that one way to make the system more
sensible is to get people who say
crazy things to write it down right so
that they can remember what they once
thought
but that's very different than
collecting information on people
and then using it to adjust their
ability to earn a living
the fact is you have to leave room for
honest disagreements
i would point out that the side that is
now going around
demonizing the trump administration and
you know that term sycophants
that does not suggest that they're even
talking about people who were formally
part of it right
they're talking about people who liked
it and
are they in fact talking about 70
million trump voters right
are they in fact talking about something
like that and in a world where we are
talking about all kinds of
crazy stuff on the far left right about
how to sort of informally restructure
all of our interactions so that the
right people end up benefiting
this is just part they talked about are
they talking about us not trump voters
but people who
said with regard to his rule on for
instance critical race
theory yeah good one keep that up right
and in fact we've seen the tech
platforms who are effectively
partnered with this ideology we've seen
them treat uh the unity movement the
same way when the unity movement was
decidedly
not trump not biden yep right so um yes
the dangers here are
uh are are many and the echoes of
history
and the punitive um nature of politics
when you have a system
that is uh less dynamic and less
fairness oriented than ours are hard to
miss
yes it is so um
oh the other thing i wanted to point out
so you've got uh
the you've got these little syllogisms
about uh
you know intent doesn't matter it's
consequences that matter
right now i can defend that sentence
but i also know what it means in these
cases
and what it means cannot be defended and
there are also
obviously places in for instance the
legal system where intent does matter
well so the idea that intent doesn't
matter has been
has been used to advance the cause of
critical race theory
and you know very illiberal practices
in so-called diversity and inclusion
trainings
um where all it takes is for me to have
taken offense
to demonstrate that you were intending
to give offense and that you have racism
in your heart or whatever it is
right right and no sorry that's not how
that works
not only is it not how it works but it
basically empowers
anyone who wants to including bad actors
who wish to abuse this power to
convict anyone they want by simply
accusing them so it is
absolutely the unin you know i would
argue nothing matters
more than intent right and that doesn't
mean so intent doesn't matter
matches certain aspects of this right if
somebody
uh runs over you know
your kid right your kid is gone
so in some sense intent doesn't affect
that parameter and from the point of
view of your grappling with the loss
it doesn't matter from the point of view
of what we do about the person
who hit your kid either through
negligence
or intent it's all the difference in the
world as it must be
right you get a crazy system if you
erase these things
and uh so anyway one has the sense that
we are dealing either
with people who don't give a crap about
the system that they are destroying
because they actually don't agree with
us
about the things that it is built to
achieve
or that they don't understand it well
enough to understand what they are
unhooking
yeah and neither of those is is
terrifying
and there's also a crucial distinction
between the analogy you just gave and
what we're actually seeing which is that
in the case
that your child gets killed by someone
in a car
and you are forever after without your
child um but the person driving the car
will suffer different consequences
regardless of whether or not
they were negligent or intentionally
trying to kill someone
the fact is that a dead child
is an objective fact and that a
large number of the claims that are
being made against
people and against for instance those
who you know
worked or were somehow sycophants in the
trump administration
are not objective facts they are claims
some of which are actually
very few of which are actually
falsifiable and falsified
and many of the rest are simply these
sort of but my feelings say i'm hurt
right now and i'm offended and therefore
what you're doing is terrible
and so not only has intent being is
intent being intentionally
erased um but the actual conclusion the
you know the thing
for which they would erase intent is
very much a subjective matter
and they would they would make claims uh
like you know asking for evidence of
racism is it self-evidence of racism
um such that you can't even believe that
the conclusion is what they say it is
yeah uh that's that's quite right and
you know let's put it this way there's a
mixture
the reason that people would do this is
a mixture of things some of them are
confused and some of them
are actually involved in a massive power
grab
and putting the rest of us at tremendous
risk um
that isn't theirs to create yeah and the
problem is
i keep running into this which is in
order to protect ourselves from these
kinds of instincts
right one has to
convey something subtle and increasingly
i think
boring and so it's very hard to get
people
to focus on why we have
counter-intuitive protections why we
don't go after
the other party when they leave office
and we feel that what they've done in
office is vile
right very hard to explain these things
and the
idea that we need to get enough of us on
board with remembering what those
structures are for
and how they work when they work and
what has happened when they failed and
why that's bad
i just can't imagine that conversation
occurring
broadly enough to to reverse the
trajectory
you know i did see
a hopeful sign there was enough traffic
uh
in the reverse where aoc was
trying to incite people to to start
cataloging who
who had committed these crimes well as i
began with it's not just her there's an
actual
you know page and people like me i've
seen it all over here it's basically
it's the
what was that what was that spreadsheet
that was started during early me too
the oh yes the bad it wasn't
it was something men in hollywood the
nasty men whatever it was
uh where this this journalist or would
be journalist i don't remember what
basically said just send me all of your
all of your names send me the name of
anyone who has been naughty
and i'm i i how could i fact check it so
i'll just put that up there and then
publicize
this this spreadsheet and you know of
course it took out a number of good
people
as well as you know presumably revealing
some truly heinous figures but the point
is an informal system like that invites
abuse of course it does
um i would also point out uh long before
candace owens was well known
um she was involved in an effort to put
together
a uh basically i hope i have this right
it was like a doxing
site um so anyway this theme keeps
getting reinvented
because it's the last person uh this was
it's a little murky as to what it was i
don't want to say because i'm not
certain about the details of it but
it's a it's it's a canonical where
people will keep reinventing the idea of
punishing those people on the other side
but i would point out okay
it is very rare these days
that people on the left will invoke the
comparison
between trump and hitler but there was a
long period there where it was not the
least bit rare
to hear that assertion and i think the
point is the idea
that in an environment where you're
going to get stuff that wrong
right that you are then going to go
about punishing people on the other side
for disagreeing with you that's
preposterous well i gather you haven't
heard that rogan is the new hitler
that seems unlikely i mean you've met
him he
doesn't really seem all that hitler no
really not but that would be exactly
what he would do wouldn't it
luring us into a false sense of security
by being so goddamn decent that would
cover it like
nothing else yeah um all right
so uh no i've actually seen um people
beginning to
suggest that rogan might be hitler
i can personally assure you that he is
not
[Laughter]
of course not but but i mean you know to
the point that people
once once you've established the need
for the devil and you know we talked
about this for the
when we were talking about hoffer's book
on mass movements
um that you know that this is akin to a
religion every good religion every
successful religion needs
some kind of a devil um that if if
hitler
if you know the the guy he would manage
to convince some number of people
was hitler is now out of here and
like who are you going to put up on the
mantle of hitler-ness
well you know rogan is apparently one of
those apparently on the
list it's incredible yeah
um yeah it's really shocking
but you need a devil you do but the
other thing to say is
in some way the
these formulations and the fact that
they are being deployed unironically
is really in some sense a measure of
just
how rare it is for people to step
outside of their filter bubble i think
you know for you and me
i'm sure that we are in a filter bubble
but it's so arbitrary on its borders by
virtue
of the fact that we are neither fish nor
foul and so
i'm sure the algorithm just hasn't
really figured us out it knows that it
we annoy it but it doesn't know
who to file us with in order to
reinforce stuff because it's
you know the belief system is eclectic
um but
you and i know because we know so many
people who
voted for trump spoke about their
reasons for doing so
weren't in the dark right and we know
lots of people who did that on the biden
side too but the point is there was a
you know a self-awareness in both cases
but if you and i know
i don't know dozens of people who could
absolutely articulate a
case for voting for trump a case that
you and i presumably didn't
agreed on because we didn't vote for him
but a case that we can recognize
and the point is who are any of these
people
to be looking at your the fact of
support for trump
as as if it was tantamount to a crime
right
no it isn't you absolutely have to have
your own
side in order before you can even look
at what's on the other side
as a moral defect because the point is
you're engaged in a moral defect too and
you know as i sometimes say we can't
hold people responsible
for making bad choices when there were
no good choices available right and
that's
that's the situation now election after
election yeah no it sure is
um okay let's talk let's talk a little
bit about what i call read-only activism
okay
okay um so this is a phrase that i
invented i believe in the wake of
the panel that i was on that you
introduced
back in february 2018 um on a day on
which we met for the first time
uh helen pluckrose james damore
peter pagozian also not on stage
um those are the people who are on stage
was peter helen james and me
um but some of the other people we met
that same day
were andy noe who was actually one of
the student leaders of the event
and uh james lindsay who was there as
well and mike nena
who many of you will be familiar with as
the documentary filmmaker
um who um uh both
revealed the uh grievance studies affair
i think is what
is what they called it and also the
three-part um
documentary on evergreen um so gosh
there were more people there that we met
as well but that was
that was the main people and um about a
half an hour into this event
and it's all it's all available on
youtube the whole two hours-ish
of the event activists stormed out and
broke some
sound equipment and uh out there
in the lobby they started making the
claim that even the women that would be
me and helen pluckrez
um were you know captured by this
ideology and probably fascist i don't
remember exactly the language they used
um and the thing literally the thing
that they stormed out
on was me saying that men and women are
different heights
on average okay and so this caught the
attention of a lot of people
because it seemed like they had just
gone too far like how
how could you disagree with this this is
actually a simple measurable parameter
what the hell and uh my point
which um i i wrote about but it's it's
just in um
it's just a medium here um you can you
can put this here
uh zach yep um so again this is from
first of march 2018 um in which you know
back then i'm saying protest is american
solidly at the heart of any democratic
society many of our cherished
institutions have a long history of
protest
and then i describe a little bit about
the panel and the disruption
just these three paragraphs i think that
we
found points of agreement and
disagreement but the protesters who
walked out
breaking the audio equipment as they
left weren't around to listen
outside unbeknownst to those of us on
the panel the individuals who left said
things like even the women in there have
been brainwashed and quote
nazis are not welcome in civil society
when banal observations like men and
women are different heights prompts the
accusation that i'm both brainwashed and
a nazi
it's clear that this was not a good
faith protest it is
true that the authoritarian left is
denying biology but the deeper truth of
the situation is perhaps even more
concerning
the incoherence of the protesters
responses and the fact that the wildcat
was scheduled in advance
which we later which we learned was true
suggests something darker
the protesters are read read-only like a
computer file that cannot be altered
they will not engage ideas they will not
even hear ideas because their minds are
already made up
they have been led to believe that
exposure information is in and of itself
dangerous
scientists philosophers and scholars of
all sorts have effectively been accused
of thought crimes before it has even
known
what we're going to say the very concept
of thought crime as orwell himself well
understood
is the death knell to discourse
discovery and to democracy
so why you know why am i bringing this
up now
given that we're you know in the wake of
this election and uh
most people it seems at least on the
left are quite sure
that um that now the protests will stop
and while it's only today that
most of the media have declared a winner
um i don't see any evidence that the
riots anyway
put aside the protests because really
they they are
related phenomena but um
but very often it's quite clear when
you're talking about riots and not
protests
um are not stopping at all so
um let me just provide a few examples
here
hold on um go back and forth a few times
we have uh the
pacific northwest youth liberation front
saying [ __ ] trump [ __ ] biden death to
america we want something better than
this trash and we're going to take it
so that was the evening the late evening
of the election
wait scroll over on that one to the next
image
whoever they vote for we are
ungovernable ungoverned
yep yeah this is so next zach thank you
um there's just a better picture of that
here whoever they vote for we are
ungovernable
with the signs of anarchy okay zach
um let's see
this we don't want biden we want revenge
for police murders imperialist wars and
fascist
massacres and maybe
if they've got a lot of remain
ungovernable
uh let's see the fight continues
post-election protest the fight
continues
we don't know what the fight is about
even at this point we're just being told
the fight continues
um and of course what we s what we've
been seeing in portland
still every night since the election is
more vandalism there is a
church uh in downtown portland
here we go is multnomah county sheriff
reporting on this church
that was doing tremendous work with
homeless which of course
portland has a huge problem with um
being vandalized sufficiently that they
have now declared that the church itself
can no longer be doing some of its work
uh with the homeless because the church
is not intact enough to do so
and then let me just one more example of
this
here's nancy robin our friend who was in
portland
for several days this week who um
was present to see for instance the wild
fang
um basically a feminist
women's fashion store had all of its
windows blown out
and um and and many and many other
things like that so i highly recommend
this article in reason if
if you haven't read it by nancy realman
so
they're they and who is they it's you
know it's a tiny fringe element among
the people who were who were in fact
protesting peacefully of course
right um for for many many months but
it's not a tiny fringe part of those
people who started rioting
reliably every night after dark for many
many months here in portland
and why is it
that they haven't changed their tune now
that the election has actually come to
pass
well because it's not actually
responsive to its environment this is
not
activism that is responsive to its
environment therefore
it should both not be taken seriously i
would say as a critique of particular
policies or politicians but it is being
taken seriously you know mayor wheeler
who we
triumphantly re-elected because by doing
so we avoided the actual antifa
candidate um
mayor wheeler and uh governor brown
who this week has been making some moves
in i think the correct direction
um but have been taking these people
seriously with their
batshit demands as if they are actually
responding
to policy and people and
at the same time as we should not be
taking their critique
as if it is actually about policy or
people given that they are telling us
it's not
we should also be taking it far more
seriously than it is as a force of
destruction and not just of windows
and not even just of individual acts of
violence of which there is plenty of
evidence
but an actual force of destruct
destruction i could not find
the couple of images that i'd seen
earlier in the week from denver and i
think from philly
which have them arguing that liberalism
itself is the enemy
death to america yeah well that's that's
the thing
is that this is a an attack
on the very fabric of
pluralistic secular society and if you
pay attention
to what it says and what it does this is
very
clear now what it has gotten good at is
reversing cause and effect
so the fact that you have a large number
of you know chardonnay
liberals with trump derangement syndrome
those people are susceptible
to partnering with anything that appears
to be equally angry about the thing that
has their focus
and so you know the whole thing that we
watched go down in slow motion here
in portland was the relentless attack
on policing and governance and authority
that
forced trump at the federal level to
bring in
dhs officers which then was portrayed as
the precipitating event for the violence
and the point is
cause and effect have been reversed what
it is that is
being sought by these protesters and
rioters
is quite clear in what they say they're
not good at keeping it under wraps
but somebody paying casual attention or
worse
somebody editing what it is that others
see can very easily portray it in the
wrong direction so that it appears to be
a reaction to something
that they themselves find um find
troubling
and i will say at first i was very
heartened to hear
governor brown's uh bringing in of the
national guard and the fact that finally
we saw a proportionate response to the
violence
where there were so just just to just to
provide some details she
declared a state of emergency in the
state of oregon from
5 pm the day before election day through
wednesday 5 pm
uh and basically allowed the possibility
that national guard would come in
and that they and i think it was
multnomah county which is the main
county that portland is in uh would have
the authority
to use tear gas such that the you know
the non-lethal means that have been
taken off the table by
mayor wheeler would now be back on the
table such that perhaps we could
actually avoid
you know state-promoted violence um
while also
actually keeping the peace and um in the
wake of the riots both election night
and
basically promises to continue at the
next night she is now cont
she has now extended that um i don't
know if it's officially the state of
emergency or just all of the stuff
around the national guard through at
least
tomorrow through at least sunday and
very much to her credit and so doing she
did not
make the usual move that we've seen in
so many
democratic municipalities and and other
uh other provinces and the like but
she said we won't tolerate violence from
the left
from the right or the center that was
her phrase and uh
anyway it was well done overdue
inexplicably but nonetheless done and
done before the election
um so uh you know good on you governor
brown
very much so um yeah the other thing
though is
we were of course very uh concerned
about the fact that mayor wheeler was
facing this challenge from sarah
iannarone
uh to his nominal left
and she was a not so cryptic supporter
of antifa so that was a very frightening
prospect
that she might win now she lost which i
initially took to be
a good sign that reason had won out and
as much as
wheeler has been a spectacular
disappointment is
an understatement to say the very least
he stood a greater chance of ultimately
coming to his senses and standing up to
this nonsense that is threatening
his city and its citizens but what i
found out later
was that in fact there had been a
substantial
write-in campaign now nobody because of
the way the ballots are reported we
cannot say whose name was written in
but the only plausible candidate to have
taken to have gotten as many write-in
votes
was actually somebody understood to be
even to the nominal left of iana roane
a founder of the group don't shoot
portland
so it is not clear at all why
ted wheeler won and whether that was an
outbreak of reason or the result
of a divided vote on the um
i hesitate to i'm going to not use an
epithet
i'm going to say the extreme illiberal
left
but um but in any case the right outcome
did happen that right outcome is still
uh very little security in light of what
wheeler has allowed well in here we have
wheeler
today i am grateful to be mayor of a
city that overwhelmingly voted for joe
biden and kamala harris
we can now move forward instead of
fighting against an administration that
tried to move us backward
we now will have a partner in the
federal government instead of an
opponent
here he is reversing cause and effect
willfully
confusedly who knows i don't
i don't think he's a dumb man so um
it's possible that he is legitimately
confused or he really you know or he saw
exactly the threat that you saw went
like wow
um actually half the people who voted in
portland more than half the people who
voted in portland i think
um voted for either someone who actively
supports antifa or someone even farther
left than her
um i don't like this description of
that's being allowed
left yeah um even more liberal than her
and is imagining that those of us who
voted for
him will put up with anything and all he
has to do is keep on moving more and
more
liberal and uh one thing that i think
you know
most the vast majority of people who
watch us and listen to us aren't in
portland but
i cannot imagine that uh
the next time the mayor of portland is
up for re-election
that the vast majority of us who still
live here however many of us that might
be at that point
will be paying such insignificant
attention that we allow
this kind of diabolical choice to show
up on the ballot again
well so the problem of course
is that i think people are
voting and signaling as if this is
all an abstraction and it is very
obvious that it will not take long
if you allow a force to break the
windows of whatever businesses it wants
and to terrorize citizens the way
the rioters have been doing night after
night
if you allow people to do this it is
obviously going to
destroy the economic base of the city
you know
it's not a place that somebody's going
to want to start a business
if there are no businesses then where is
the tax base
right so you know people are voting
in a way that completely up ends the
capacity of the city to be governed well
now you know to the extent that there's
a defense
for you know a liberally minded city
it's you want one that is capable of
accomplishing
things that others can't you want you
know better transportation you want
you know safer cleaner streets you you
know you want the city to function well
and in fact that's the slogan portland
is the city that works right
is that right oh i didn't know that yeah
that's amazing
right but the thing is it's very easy to
upend that
and then the point is everybody's worse
off and so
whatever your liberal values have you
pursuing you've undone them by virtue of
the fact that there's nothing to do
those things with
yeah well so just a couple more minutes
on portland on
politics that are local to us here there
is something
something good that happened um that is
an
actual positive as opposed to a you know
very much a lesser of two evils which is
the
situation with the mayoral race in
portland um but i'm going to start with
something that's
uh definitely not so good um why won't
it open
um okay well i can't open that site for
some reason
okay um so city commissioner um dan ryan
i'm trying to open this link from well
i'm at week
um and zach's going to try to open it
for me but now i can't read my notes
um so um dan ryan who was an extent
um city commissioner and who was not um
being
being who's not on the ballot this
this year voted against an 18 million
cut to the police budget
and a mob came to his house in the
middle of the night and
vandalized it and put up flares in front
and this is in part what prompted
governor brown to say actually we're
extending the um
the either the emergency order at least
parts of it then allow the national
guard and the multnomah county sheriff's
office to
oversee and give more power to the
portland police bureau so i actually
don't need that anymore zach
i i'm done talking about it um so i need
my screen back though
please so that i can go to the next one
um so that's all
terrible but what isn't terrible is
this we had um this commissioner-elect
mingus maps
uh who is a former political science
professor
who is black who is um you know they
call him conservative but what that
means in portland i actually have no
idea
um uh he uh won
against incumbent chloe utility who was
very much
in line with sort of ian around and
hardesty and um
some of the other like actually get rid
of the police
um people uh has um
stood up already like he's he's just a
commissioner elect and yet somehow
uh he was allowed to also vote against
the 18 million dollar
defunding of the police that happened
this week
and he says
this campaign of intimidation and
vandalism against commissioner ryan must
stop
map said mobs have descended on his
house in the middle of the night in
order to intimidate him and devoting the
way they want
it happened again last night that's true
it happened two nights running a mob
descended on his house broke windows and
sprayed paint on his home
maps was joined on a press call by about
a dozen black community leaders
his remarks were significant in part
because they signaled a new dynamic in
city hall
a black man will be among the most
conservative members of the council
and he is wielding the language of civil
rights and equity to condemn the
excesses
of a protest movement that also says it
is seeking racial justice
well how [ __ ] lilia that's that's
amazing that
is amazing that i this is one of the few
things that actually really gives me
hope right now from this election
yeah i agree that's a um a
a rare but unambiguous sign of reason
yeah um so all right
that's that's all from portland good on
you mr maps yeah um
okay so let's see where are we
are there more topics i have a few
things
to end with um at your suggestion that
just
to end with that are unrelated to
politics all right well before we close
out the politics let me ask you
um do you have a sense of what should
happen
now in light of the um
the gardening store
press conference and landscaping
supplies man
landscape supplies landscape sorry
landscaping supplies
press conference um the uh
allegations the four seasons landscaping
company the force i have to say there is
something delightful about the president
having tweeted that they were going to
have a press conference the four seasons
absolutely and the journalist who i
first heard about it from called the
four seasons of philadelphia is like you
sure it's not there
they're like yes sir it's at the
landscaping company
all right can we just all agree whatever
side you're on there's something
charming about that story charming
or you know they're calling around and
they're like oh no no you cannot have
your press conference here
no you could but even that i kind of
like right
you know look this president is paying a
huge price
for what i would call failures of
taste right right the four seasons was
not going to help that a landscape
supply shop
in some way is a nice counterpoint i
think to a press conference held at the
four seasons hotel
yeah um okay so we've got
these allegations and legal maneuvers on
the one side
we've got the uh blue
world of media and i will say the red
world of media
you've got fox in the wall street
journal also declaring
oh yeah the election well i mean we
didn't even talk about the fact that fox
declared arizona for trump before anyone
else did and like stuck with it for days
and i mean it's still not frankly clear
that arizona won't actually flip back to
red right um i don't actually know what
the state of that is for the last couple
of hours but
yes i meant for biden sorry um they
declared it for biden and it's not clear
to me that it won't flip
um but you know they were the first and
um you know it enraged partisan hacks on
the right
yeah like i you know we thought you were
our partisan hackery network it's like
actually
fox is trying to report the news right
and um and apparently actually i don't
have the details of this so i may get
some of this wrong but apparently after
the last election when the polls were so
wrong
i believe it was the ap and fox
uh basically formed some kind of an
alliance with a different
a different predictive polling outfit
because it was so clear that what
everyone was relying on which is
basically everyone at that point
had gotten it really wrong so um they
were looking at different
you know the hopefully the votes of the
votes
right but the predictions about what
they're going to be
and how fast they're going to be counted
and how many they're ultimately going to
be before they're all counted in all of
this
is is the work of pollsters and
statisticians
and those predictions will vary by what
models you're um you're using
so fox was apparently using different
models this time than all the rest of
the
media
except for i think the associated press
and uh
and they had a different they you know
they
went against type and um
which could mean a lot of things i have
to say sure um sure it's a little hard
to know
what it means and you know let's not
forget that uh
trump was not the establishment
candidate on the right he
more or less beat the gop in the primary
with help
from hillary clinton and the dnc of all
people
and of all organizations and effectively
decapitated
the the gop and took over now
i don't know is this the establishment
part of the gop
reestablishing itself right in other
words did they
go after a weakened trump um
because i mean calling arizona before
anyone else doesn't
it doesn't necessarily mean going after
trump well
i let's put it this way
i detect a very straight um
presentation from fox yeah
relatively we were mostly watching nbc i
guess it was
um but um but yeah nbc's uh nbc's
coverage when we looked at it
seemed pretty pretty straight but let's
just say i i saw the same story almost
across fox wall street journal
uh pbs cbs nbc you know new york times
and so that could mean any one of a
number of things but
um i just want to be agnostic about
what's actually going on here because
the landscape is
uh so rich so confused
and misleading and the players
you know it's not very long ago that
trump was
a challenge to the very core of the gop
and then he became synonymous with the
gop and so what happens
in a case where you know you've got a
squeaker of an election
i don't know um i will say
you know you say let's hope that the
votes of the votes let's hope that the
votes are the votes
uh there's and we will never know we
will very likely never know
um i would hope that we would know with
greater certainty than we do now
but we will never know everything we
will never know
everything and i have to say there's one
place legally speaking
um there are very strict regulations i
have now learned about
um about the voting the
the dead voting right and it even
extends to people who
vote by mail and then die
their votes don't count so these things
are very
tightly regulated really so if on
election day you're dead even if you
voted early
legally your vote is not supposed to
count which
makes sense in a weird way because i was
actually i was wondering exactly this
yeah i mean this is going to apply to so
very very few
it's not a it's not a large constituency
no
but yes um uh but nonetheless that you
know
it makes sense because the fact is
imagine that there were no mail in
voting then the point is
if you're there voting you're alive um
and so
we should not be skewed right
but the other thing is you know
legalities aside
in the case of people voting from beyond
the grave
i mean in this case i think it's fair
for people who died of covet
what's fair i wouldn't be able to vote
from beyond the grave
i just think in this case the
mishandling of the covet epidemic
actually gives
them a certain number of rights that i
wouldn't extend more broadly
you're arguing for special rights for
the coveted i see i am okay
i just morally that feels right to me
you're looking at me with that look in
your eyes that you get sometimes
well all right
shall we move on move on to the final
non-political or nominally non-polar
well actually just two more quick notes
about the state of the world
um the smithsonian magazine has reported
that there is a global shortage of
anti-venom
for venomous snake bites and the
guardian has reported a surge in
white shark sightings off the coast of
california so
in case you felt like things outside of
politics were doing fine nope
nope they're not no sorry i wanted to
say one more thing before we close this
out given that we are at this
singular moment in history was it the
anti-venom or the sharks
no it was neither it was me remembering
that i had something
so i i don't know what you think should
happen
now right oh yeah i never answered that
question today
do you have a should happen now
it depends on what level we're talking
about maybe maybe let's save
why don't you go on okay i have a few at
different levels so here's
here's my my sense um
and mind you i at least am consistent in
this way over my lifetime we've had
parallels to this situation and my
advice would have been
similar even to uh to people across the
aisle but my sense is
that what has already unfolded
with trump and the trump administration
in the context of this election
means that ultimately he will not
be seated as president even if there is
some fraud in the election and i haven't
seen compelling evidence of that yet but
it's
of course possible um that
the sequence of events that would result
in him staying would look like a an
intense battle
over balloting yeah in which
uh you know we are very unlikely to get
to the truth but you know as in 2000 we
could get to a
win that would award votes
right it could end up in the supreme
court which of course is a fraught venue
at this moment
anyway because of uh ruth bader
ginsburg's death
and so the the fact is
even in trump fantasy world yeah
him remaining in office is at
such spectacular cost to the nation
in terms of are already
distrusting and at each other's throats
nature that my argument would be look
um trump did not do a good job
in the run-up to the election in fact he
did an appalling job
ceding the idea that the election was
going to be stolen
that compromises him dramatically with
respect to
claims that it has been stolen i feel
like you mean that he actually
did a really good job of seeding that
idea which was a dishonorable thing to
be doing
was a dishonorable thing to be doing and
he did it effectively
which means that now his claiming that
the election has been stolen
is in the context that he set in motion
yeah he's boy he's a boy who cried wolf
territory
on the other hand if there's actually a
wolf and you're the only one who's
seeing it right like you know so there
there's
you can do a both sides of this analysis
story you can but i guess my point would
be this
look i and
i believe that presidents should be
patriotic and
this should be so much a prerequisite
for the job that we should never have
had one that wasn't
i don't think that's where we are i
think that the game
that gets you there is actually not very
consistent with patriotism because in
effect
patriotism uh requires
self-sacrifice is built into it right
that it is the core of patriotism
is self-sacrifice and ruthless political
self-promotion
is the opposite but in this case the
point is look
the well-being of the nation does depend
on a peaceful transition
and as our friend ryan pointed out in a
discussion this morning
the concession speech is actually
a vital piece of this process that the
fact of the winner and the loser
agreeing on what has
happened and then events unfolding
downstream of that even though that's
not technically what happens technically
the ballots get counted official you
know
calls are made those official calls
result in the
electoral college doing what it does
formally which doesn't happen for weeks
anyway
right but the point is the most
important part of the process may be the
winner and the loser
converge on an interpretation of what
has happened and that kicks the
narrative into the next mode
and we go forward and so the point is
and grace in concession
allows both demonstrates your patriotism
and allows for the country to come back
together i actually saw um
i saw george bush's of all people his
concession speech
um in 1992 and you know this
was no fan of that guy at all he was
that was he was voted in 88 in the first
election that we were ever
able to vote in and um
and yet he gives a cons session speech
at the point that clinton beats him
uh that is that is terrific it's
it's short um you know it could be that
it doesn't mean it
but he appears to mean it and it is
gracious
and he says we're going to work with the
new administration during transition to
make sure that we have
um that we basically empower them with
everything that they can be empowered
with
so that they help make this country as
strong and productive and all of this as
possible
and and that's the key thing is it's a i
don't know if there's a there must be a
term for it but it's like the political
equivalent of good sportsmanship
yeah and it is so vital to
the functioning of the
nation that i believe this this ought to
be the focus right now and so i guess my
point to trump which i assume he doesn't
listen to the podcast but
if he does what i would like him to
think about is let's say
that you won an improbable series of
victories in courts that then resulted
in the supreme court delivering
a verdict that caused you to be
inaugurated
in january you would be inaugurated in a
country
that was so bitterly divided over what
had happened
that it would be diminished in its power
spectacularly and you would be governing
in that environment which
is just simply not good for the country
so
my argument is that the patriotic thing
to do
is to realize this was a very close
election
that that effectively makes it something
like a coin flip so
in some weird sense uh
the the winds didn't blow
his direction and that graciously
accepting that result and stepping aside
uh in an honorable way is actually
both in the interest of the nation and
also in the interest
of his legacy and the judgment that
history will
will render on him and so um you know
that's what leadership looks like and
and i hope he will show it in this case
i'm not sure i agree uh and i don't i
think
maybe we should talk about this next
time um
that sounds completely right
unless it really was stolen well
so you know remember my point is at some
level
stolen is not the right description for
what
big tech did in the context of this
election but i think we already know
that this was not a free and fair
election in the way that the founders
uh viewed it this was a this was an
election on a slanted playing field
fair enough okay so put it put aside any
question of ballot tampering and
and all of this um slanted playing field
in a toss-up uh of course the coin came
down the way
the people who would slander the playing
field wanted it to
yeah it is both you know not in keeping
with apparently who he is as a person
but um it's not clear that that it would
honor um honor
the half of the people who voted almost
um
for him for him to uh
for him to step out of the fight either
and i'm not i'm not
saying that the country can afford an
extended fight
and you know it certainly wouldn't be
good for him to be
literally dragged out on january 21st or
whatever inauguration day
is which would of course happen you know
just like
if you know just like in portland if the
police
and others had been allowed to do their
jobs they could have shut this [ __ ] down
yeah um trump is not going to like you
know
inhabit the white house beyond you know
inauguration day if biden's the winner
just not going to happen
but you know for
for how long is it appropriate
is it patriotic and you know i don't i
don't i don't think of him as a patriot
i don't think he is a patriot
but presumably many of the 70
million-ish people who voted for him are
and you know what what what about their
voices
if there really were shenanigans here uh
that we deserve to know about well
look i don't disagree i'm a big believer
in the democratic uh control mechanism
of our
republic um and you know the fact that
it's so corrupted is
part of what animates me as you know
yeah my sense is that this
cannot be settled here will not be
settled here and if it were settled here
let's put it this way
it's either settled here in a direction
that goes against him
and that doesn't change anything about
the representation of the people that
you're referring to
or it gets settled in his direction in
in which case the uh
the damage that is done in this process
is so spectacular in a context where we
can least afford it right we're in a
fragile condition rather than an
anti-fragile one
so anyway the obvious analogy being uh
to the 2000 election
and uh you know many of us were
grievously disappointed by
the supreme court's decision that tossed
that to bush too
rather than to gore um it's impossible
to know
what kind of an effective or ineffective
president he would
have been absent 911 happening so soon
upon his inauguration
um but it's also true that as much as he
was
easy to um dismiss for most of us on the
left
as an effective statesman he was not
divisive
in anything like the way that trump is
divisive we thought he was divisive at
the time but now we've
seen this much better um but you know
it would you know the dismissals were
about things like wow he would prefer to
be clearing brush on his ranch
yeah as opposed to actually leaving the
free world all right so
then i guess um my position is this
and i have not refreshed my memory on
what happened at the end of the 2000
election but my recollection is
there was absolutely an honorable way to
continue
counting and this was artificially
stopped which seated
bush and would have ceded gore had the
counting continued and so my point
that's right my point would be that
the sausage making involved in
presidential
balloting and elections has already
stolen an election for one side it's not
like that's a new phenomenon
and my point uh i think some of some
people will have seen
my tweet where i pointed out that unity
had behind the scenes been trying to
create
a prize that would have incentivized the
uh the rapid creation
of a um a secure
and um what's the word um
i can't remember the word when i uh
about an auditable
balloting mechanism in the form of an
app
so the point is look this was a
perfectly predictable catastrophe
right we saw this coming and let me tell
you what happened when unity tried to
get this
thing jump started the idea was you can
never adopt
a new technology for standardizing the
way
that we vote because so many
municipalities and states are involved
in this process
independently and there's no way to hurt
all those cats in the same direction
and so our thought was if we incentivize
the construction of the app that
accomplishes the goal
then at the point that the catastrophe
predictably unfolds the point will be
no there is a solution and it looks like
this
and the problem is there wasn't enough
enthusiasm because it wouldn't have
gotten
it wouldn't have been ready in time to
save us from this one which then means
that we will be in this
same situation down the road and so okay
we've got
a couple of elections in which um
something has happened that should have
been avoided by a
modern and coordinated way of dealing
with the ballots
and it's now time for us to do that yeah
it's just it's not um it doesn't grab
the imagination because it's not sexy
right you know it's uh a tech fix to
deal
with nefarious political maneuvers the
only thing sexy in that sentence is
nefarious
well i i disagree with you i actually
think it is kind of sexy right
there is like an example i think is it
estonia that has done this
there isn't there is an example of some
place you don't expect who has actually
gone fully modern in this regard and
solve the problem
okay and but if it is estonia i don't
know does estonia have a population
that's like that of oh i don't know
georgia
right for instance it's tiny state but
the point is it's an idea you know it's
doable
um now there's argument about that there
are lots of sophisticated people who say
you can't do this and the reason is
because you will create
a nightmare there is no system you could
build that would make the problem better
because if somebody hacked into the
system this that and the other
now our belief in unity looking at this
is that there
are solutions to this problem but you
have to be very
uh you have to be very broad-minded to
see
what the real problems are and figure
out how you fix them in such a way
that we're there uh that a a hack is
very unlikely
b that if it happened that you would
detect it and be able to reverse
engineer
what it actually happened that is
possible but in any case
we should certainly be having that
discussion broadly because
boy did we see this exact moment coming
and let me tell you it's coming again
all right enough politics
yep okay i already mentioned snakes yes
and sharks
so uh at some level my biologist self
job here is done let's talk about
perfume briefly
of course that's the next logical thing
the next logical thing this will be the
last thing we talked about before going
uh taking a break and moving on to
before your super chat question is a
mostly peaceful
transition to the q a that is what i'm
expecting no
100 peaceful transition to the q a fair
enough we can set that as a goal i mean
unless we put cream up there and only
let one of the cats at it or something
right that would that's where the mostly
would come in yeah yeah
okay so um you have heard us talk before
i believe
about luca turin um who was
highlighted in chandler bird's terrific
book the emperor of scent which i
failed to bring here um so look a turn
yeah you might be on one of the shelves
right here
okay um so luca turin is an
extraordinary heterodox scientist
who has a hypothesis that has a
tremendous amount of
scientific support behind it not no has
a tremendous amount of actual
data support behind it um
that it has more explanatory power than
the status quo explanation
for how smell works and it has been
roundly ignored by the scientific
establishment um in fact
after he had already been sort of making
the rounds talking about and providing
his evidence
you know biology chemistry physics
evidence for for his model for how smell
works
after it was already out there in the
world the nobel was actually given to
the competing not as fully explanatory
hypothesis the shapists
over and over in small space so you
wanna add something i wanna correct what
you said he has been
um loudly and aggressively ignored
i would say did i say quietly i just
said roundly yes roundly which
sounds like people just like uh like he
he wasn't there but no this was a very
uh vociferous kind of ignoring that they
did to him
yes um they practically made fun of what
he was wearing right if everything else
right
it's a it's a little tell that yeah when
things are afoot in science space
indicates yes something is a mess highly
recommend the emperor of scent which is
again chandler burr's
um basically a count of luke returns
uh move through the scientific
establishment and finally having no
choice but to say like well
you know i i'm still pretty sure i'm
right i still i
still think that i have the correct
mechanism for how smell works
um it's a better fit for the data it's a
better fit for what we know but um
but i can't get anywhere so to hell with
it
but turin is not just a brilliant
scientist across all these domains you
know biology chemistry physics
he's also got an extraordinary nose
which is not something before i read the
emperor of scent that i really thought
about much
um so in this book perfumes the guide
which is not something i just
bought and i wouldn't have even thought
to really by by luca turin
and his um partner in in
perfumery and also i believe his wife
tanya sanchez
um he and his he and sanchez review
hundreds of perfumes
uh and for those of us like us who don't
traffic and perfumes we just don't i
know the names of maybe a couple
many more from having become familiar
with turin's work here
most of us will never heard of many or
maybe even any of these but the reviews
themselves are just
glorious okay so i want to read a few of
these
reviews and without any expectation that
you know what any of these perfumes are
they've given for each of them a scale
of one to five stars where five is a
masterpiece four is recommended
three is good two is not good one is
avoid
and um for each review they also give a
two word
phrase that describes it um describes
the smell
so um there are several four and five
star reviews i'm going to read one four
star review
uh and then and then a number the one
star reviews because they're
particularly
fun so just the four-star review so you
can get a sense
of and most of these are actually most
of the rest of the stuff in the book is
written
by sanchez and most of the reviews
themselves are written by turin
you need to find the actual pages
usually they come in order right okay so
here we have
um
no we don't what it's not on the right
page somehow i wrote the wrong page
number down
um here we have on a totally different
page than what i wrote down
cap neroli uh four stars uh the two word
description they give is capsicum
indole not an oda clone at all despite
the beautifully bright resinoid citrus
start
when it settles down to what it settles
down to is an intensely endolic orange
blossom
which reminds me of jasmine incense in
the various household ancestor shrines
of my mother's friends
not a fresh white blossom but a dark
quiet smell that really should belong to
sticky black syrups and medicinal
bottles
behind it a peculiar peppery angle adds
to the feeling of mystery
as so often with the fragrances of
patricia de nicolai
it is slightly more than and different
from what you would expect
to extend the excellent top note wear on
fabric so that's the sort of
classic description and um you know of a
of one that he enjoys by the way if this
sounds like nonsense to you if it sounds
like astrology where a bunch of vague
stuff is being thrown at things
it is not at all if you read the emperor
of scent you will find yourself
going into perfume stores and smelling
these things and you can actually
i mean it's amazing how much
dimensionality there is there's a
temporal dimension
uh and these things that you would have
no ability to describe which he just
does a marvelous
job of uh rendering yeah he pulls up but
then you know it's mostly by analogy to
other things because
english like i think an emperor of scent
they say every language that they've
that they've looked at although i'm not
sure it's everyone but
at least almost all in every every
language is really depoppered with
regard to words that describe smell
you know english is particularly vision
oriented and you would expect languages
to be because primates are particularly
vision-oriented having sort of taken
over
um the smell part of our brain for for
optical processing
um but there are some other languages
that are more
hearing oriented uh in terms of the
richness of the metaphors
that they have but there aren't any that
are you know that are smell focused
we just don't have the languaging for it
and yet here we have turin and sanchez
really
really nailing it so i have five five
one star reviews
so these are not the best perfumes in
the uh these are in fact
not the best perfumes
lay concentrate two word description
condensed fail if you take an unopened
tin of sweet condensed milk and boil it
in a saucepan of water for several hours
you get
courtesy of the maillard reaction a
brown semi-solid marvel
which argentinians who suffer no
shortage of cows
called dolce de leche les concentres
this perfume is a failed attempt to
replicate the rich and complex glory of
the real thing
one has to ask though even were it
accurate why would anyone want to smell
like condensed milk
i wouldn't no so from the same house
from the same perfume house
we have lay de biscuit i don't know
actually how you pronounce biscuit in
french bisqui
um for which their two word description
again a one star
review is defective biscuit
[Music]
the thing he writes about the smell of
baked goods as any flavorist will tell
you
is that the recursive chemistry that
happens at high temperatures yields an
intricate mixture of aroma chemicals
that satisfies precisely because complex
replicating the main impact materials in
a poverty-stricken composition
and claiming that this will quote awake
childhood memories
grievously underestimates human memory
intelligence
and sense of smell awful
he just pulls no punches uh the third of
five
one star reviews of perfume that luca
turned shares in this fabulous
guide lady's car written with tanya
sanchez
is trastavere one star
the two word description is milk caramel
trust a very is so preposterously awful
that it can serve to calibrate one's
perfumery scale on
zero if my date wore this on arrival i
would cancel our reservations
drag her through a car wash then say
goodbye forever
the accord described as artemisia
pallida wormwood in the pr
smells like a monster dulce de leche
flavor base with a little skank added
everything that is wrong and unholy
about caramel flavored coffee is here
repackaged to harm innocent bystanders
penultimate one star review from um
called buenissimo bonicissimo no
buenissimo
two word description is hazelnuts coca
no hazelnuts cocoa one
sentence review utterly revolting
flavored coffee nutella thing
and finally
and there's so many more 50 milliliters
dembiguitay
is the name of the perfume the two word
description for this one star review is
sweaty uranus
lukaturan advises wear this grow a messy
beard
sit on a park bench talk loudly to
yourself answer back
and soon enough they'll take you away
hose you down for free
and give you warm soup
so um you might not expect to find humor
in a perfume guide of all places but
this guy both of them can write and they
pull no punches and it's hilarious and
even if you don't own any perfume at all
or are thinking of buying any um if you
want something to laugh about right now
i recommend this book it's like a it's
like a
a christopher hitchens for old faction
yes
exactly exactly yeah
so there we go all right well we have
arrived at this
second book end to the 53rd dark horse
podcast live stream we will be back in
a few minutes to do q a 15 minutes is
that right 15 minutes
to answer your questions that you wrote
in this hour and that you write in next
hour on super chat
yep join us at our patreons join us at
our patreons
and uh you know we would just be so
grateful
if you would absolutely obliterate that
like button
subscribe to the channel hit notify
leave a comment tell us what you want
clipped and broadcast into the universe
all those things are good
yeah so we have a separate clips channel
darkhorse podcast clips uh
which is also moving along quite a clip
itself
moving along it quite a clip i like it
okay
we will see you in 15. be well
you